la mauvaise gestion de dominique anglade
paix du parti libéral lorsqu'il y avait
eu une aide d'un milliard trois cents
millions
d'ailleurs le prêt le montant total
devrait être a dit l'on ne les québécois
ont perdu un milliard trois cents
millions
isabelle dostaler maintenant et doyenne
de la faculté de l'administration des
affaires à l'université mémorial de
terre-neuve bonsoir isabelle dostaler
bonsoir faut-il encore aider soutenir
financer prêter de l'argent devenir
actionnaire public de bombardier ça
devient que décourageant c'est un peu la
tête parfaite c'est difficile c'est un
moment difficile c'est sûr maintenant
c'est recentrer exclusivement sur
l'aviation d'affaires et puis bon la
crise étant ce qu'elle est en ce moment
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes quant à
quant à ce marché
la question c'est comme si on aurait eu
envie de répondre à cette question il ya
plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années quand
l'entreprise était été et une plus
grande entreprise je pense que le
secteur de l'aérospatiale demeure
secteur important pour le canada il faut
jamais oublier qui a pas seulement
bombardier aussi tous les autres joueurs
autour de l'entreprise donc le pays en
général bénéficient de l'existence de
bombardier et on le répète souvent il
n'ya pas de l'industrie mme secteur
aérospatial possible sans support de
l'état
on y voit un hymne aux états unis jamais
les états unis vont laisser tomber ben
ali
on le voit la même chose avec m de salon
on répète toujours un peu la même chose
mais en ce moment ça va ça va pas très
bien
non mais là il ya la cuvée 2009 tu viens
tout ébranlées qui ébranle tout secteur
qui vraiment après deux de se repenser
et de ceux de se restructurer et la
question fondamentale c'est de savoir
est ce que ça vaut la peine d'aider
encore bombardier ce que bombardier sera
encore une entreprise active dans le
domaine des avions d'affaires dans
quelques années
c'est passé c'est comme si la de ne pas
les aider
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ne pas léser
ça veut dire qu'on les laisse aller est
ce que ça veut dire
il ya tout ce problème de la gouvernance
de bombardier on a souvent dit bon la
famille par exemple possèdent une
minorité d'action mais la majorité du
pouvoir décisionnel et on a toujours dit
bon ça ça nous protègent contre une
prise de contrôle hostile
est ce qu'une prise de contrôle hostile
serait si mauvaise
ats qu'on serait ce au fond si on
regarde la série c qui deviendra le lan
220 qui sera peut-être un excellent
projet on voit ce qui est arrivé avec
l'a380 d'airbus
il n'est plus en service donc l'idée
d'un très gros appareil surtout avec ce
qu'on vit en ce moment avec cette
pandémie ça rend les plus petits
appareils plus intéressant martic le
même calcul pourrait se faire dans la
viol pour les avions d'affaires auprès
ce rebond il peut être plus sécuritaire
de voyager dans un petit groupe sion
peut se le permettre à bord d'un avion
d'affaires mais je pense que c'est
l'idée de cette propriété canadienne à
laquelle on tenait tellement est ce que
est ce que c'est ce qui est devenu pour
nous est ce que ça vous est ce que ça
vaut encore quelque chose parce que
est-ce que l'avenir de bombardier
devrait se jouer de rené vincent le
contrôle de la famille beaudoin
bombardier est ce qu'on pourrait aller
jusque là gouvernement du québec
gouvernement du canada dire pensez vous
et on va aider mais ça le contrôle de la
famille beaudoin de bombardier
je pense qu'on est en effet assez près
de cette question et je pense que toute
la question de la rémunération dans les
bêlements le parachute doré
le fait que
alors les hauts gestionnaires et la
famille ce sens on s'en doute bien sorti
ans alors c'est assez difficile d'avoir
d'un côté l'aide de l'état et de l'autre
la famille et les hauts dirigeants qui
se servent et dieu sait que j'ai
tellement été souvent au front pour
défendre les projets le pont mardi pour
défendre vraiment la syrie mais je pense
que la question de tous les bonis la
question c'est est fort mal avisée qui
en même temps du côté de l'entreprise on
dira toujours bon les salaires sont
payés c'est ce qui subsiste selon ce qui
se fait sur le marché
et oui c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
système capitaliste et ont fait cette
équation entre si on veut embaucher du
talent il faut payer l'ont embauché éric
martel on pense qu'il va qui qui peut
bien faire le travail mais il y pose
pays n'est pas rémunéré mais autant que
monsieur que monsieur vainement les tech
aussi si on veut tenter de regarder les
choses de façon un peu plus positive
eric mathais lors quand même connaît
quand même bien pour la division des
avions d'affaires
alors peut-être qui ça peut donner une
certaine une certaine confiance pu
regarder aussi ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est intéressant sur le marché
le cours de l'action de boeing va
relativement bien ces jours ci un peu
comme si les investisseurs voyaient bon
une sortie de crise
peut-être une reprise éventuelle du
transport aérien alors ça il est
possible de voir les choses de façon
positive mais quand même faut être
prudent parce qu'ils ont énormément
d'incertitudes alors faut-il encore et b
c'est une question extrêmement difficile
et je pense que si on aide
il faut vraiment que ça soit à certains
conditions et il faut bien se dire que
les américains aident énormément leur
industrie de rentrer à l'espace et à les
états aux états unis sont très
interventionniste quand on veut avoir un
constructeur bon qui s'installe dans un
état on
vas y on aide nous au canada n'est
toujours frileux je voudrais toujours un
petit peu plus catholique que le pape
plomb on a comme considérant toujours
une certaine gêne et c'est ça les règles
du jeu finalement on est on est oui dans
un libre marché mais en même temps dans
ce domaine là les états investissent
alors on peut on peut faire un calcul
nos visions tout le reste la grappe
aérospatiale très importante vous avez
raison isabelle on va s'arrêter ici
isabelle dostaler merci merci